fabi needless to say you've had a very
tough tournament so far uh you must have
been pretty devastated after the two
losses in a row
what was your mindset coming into today
yeah i mean those are really bad games i
mean most of my games in the tournament
were bad
so i i thought maybe just to play one
normal game would be nice
and i'm not sure if it was a good game
but
at least it was uh it was a very big
step up from the previous rounds
you seem to be torturing him at some
point it looked to you looks like you
had
like he had a draw you're thinking this
could be a draw but let's
let's torture him a little bit and get
him down on the clock did you see this
idea that you eventually played coming
far off
um i don't remember exactly when i
spotted this sack
um
at some point i realized that it's a
fortress
and then
yeah it was probably like 10 moves back
that i was trying to find the
the most accurate way to do this um
and i thought it can't be winning
but there was no risk and
i was actually really surprised because
when i like way back i thought that you
know i put my bishop on f6 bishop on h7
um
like
i think we were both looking at at this
sort of fortress
like 20 moves prior and just moving
around waiting to get it and i thought
that you know
i'll play
yeah like e5 bishop f7
or at any moment yeah like we had in the
game
so a lot of uh dancing around
get this position well here his king is
on i think if it's on e8 then i'd have
no ideas
but it's on this side so
suddenly sacrifices become
viable because his king is so far away
from everything
by now you've seen the idea
yeah yeah i'd seen it a bit in advance i
just wanted to calculate it
because once we get here
he'll start to calculate it and i didn't
i wanted him to be low on time and not
and to not have
time really to look at the position
after king c5 so that was intentional on
your part to get him down on the clock
well i i mean i don't think it's winning
so the best chance is that he's in time
trouble
and that i have a bit more time so you
so i just want to direct answer the
question you did want him to get into
time pressure before you went for it i i
mean i can answer this for this game and
for all other games i'm happy when my
opponents are in time pressure
well it wasn't quite the question but
i'll i'll leave you alone on that one so
now he's in time pressure and you start
to to look at it did you see it did you
still think it had to be a draw i
assumed it's a draw i mean i have one
pawn for the piece it's actually
surprising that it's as difficult for
him as it is but i didn't see a clear
way to draw which was
i figured that
that was already a good sign at least he
has to find some tough moves his king is
very bad his pawns are all falling um i
assume there's a draw but i don't know
exactly where right here the engine
gives a study like draw after knight e4
and c5
yeah c5 i thought so bc
and then the com i know here it gives
king f7 as the drawing oh yeah i was
looking at knight d2 but that looked
winning
um
yeah king of seven i didn't consider
but e6 k7 yeah
i think g5 was the main move and now
knight d2
yeah it's really difficult for black
yeah to find those means like good luck
exactly
that was what we felt too fabby i mean
it just
uh
practically speaking
you you take no risk right right
there's no risk there's no risk and
at the end you underpromote it to a
bishop
you know usually the computers give that
as the best move because it
gives up the least amount of material is
that why you did it no i've just never
done that before right so i might as
well take the first time in your life
under promoting to a bishop i don't
remember having ever under promoted to a
bishop no knight is common right
uh even in middle games right there's
some famous
um famous combinations like with uh
queen h6 queen h8 things like that and
and and the fork of the queens um
but bishop is really on
it's pretty rare i mean usually only
seen studies when there's a stalemate
things like that but
in a practical game you almost never
have any reason to promote to a bishop
so it felt good to do is what you're
saying yeah
absolutely all right well
we thought
you needed to score maybe four or four
and a half maybe more like four and a
half out of five to finish
if you want to have a realistic chance
of fighting for the championship were
you thinking about that at all or you're
just thinking this game and the rest no
i stopped looking at the scores even i
mean i i don't know
when you're minus one and you're playing
really horribly uh you shouldn't be
thinking about the winning tournament
maybe if uh
i get some momentum and things start to
go my way then
i can start to think about it again but
um but it's still tough and at least i'm
happy that
uh that i got on the scoreboard
all right well congratulations
on a fighting win good luck the rest of
the way thank you fantastic victory fabi
on behalf of christian and i it was
really really amazing well done well
done well done yeah
what are they